we have lost far too many lives
traveling the path to this day since
1937 over 2,000 people have died at the
Golden Gate Bridge I feel lucky to be
alive every single day the thousands
that have died off the Golden Gate
Bridge I am of the 1% who have survived
so I was born on drugs and premature and
then I bounced around prom to home
nobody wanted to keep me because I was
sick and I got lucky I landed in the
home of Patrick and Deborah Hines I had
a great childhood
I thought growing up that everything's
gonna be great and then at 17 it all
came crashing down if you can imagine
feeling that everyone around you is out
to get you
trying to hurt you and trying to kill
you and you believe that to be the truth
from the extreme paranoia I exhibited
symptoms of mania from the mania came
the hallucinations both auditory and
visual and so with that and the bipolar
disorder I just was spiraling out of
control I vividly remember writing my
suicide note people don't get it like I
thought I was a burden to everyone who
loved me because that's what my brain
told me because that's how powerful your
brain is I got off the bus I walked
slowly down the walkway that going Gate
Bridge you know people rode by me drove
by me walked by me and a woman
approached me and she said will you take
my picture she said thanks and she
walked away there's that moment I just
said nobody cares reality was that
everybody cared I just couldn't see it
I ran forward and using my two hands I
catapulted myself into freefall what I'm
about to say is the exact same thing
that nineteen Golden Gate Bridge jump
survivors have also said the millisecond
my hands left the rail it was an instant
regret and I remember thinking no one's
gonna know that I didn't want to die in
four seconds I fell 75 miles an hour 25
stories and I hit the water I was in the
most physical pain I've ever experienced
I have ever experienced
the Coast Guard was amazing he was just
so freaked out that I was alive that he
just dove in and brought me on board and
I said do you know how many people we
pull out its water that
dad and I said no and I don't want to
know that put his hand on my forehead I
said kid you're a miracle my father took
one step into the hospital room and I
looked up at him and I said dad I'm
sorry
he said no Kevin I'm sorry and if you
think about it both of our immediate
reactions were guilt guilt that didn't
belong to either of us and even though I
didn't die I caused people a great deal
of grief and pain just the day of my
attempt still sits within them today I
asked my father if he still feared my
death by suicide he said every time the
phone goes off his first inclination is
Kevin alive I had an impact on my dad so
after the jump the road to recovery was
pretty long
I had seven psych wards days in the next
11 years I I still have all the symptoms
I ever had
mania and depression psychosis
hallucinations all that still there I
just not have cope with it and I know
how to beat it I built a support network
over these years of treatment so that I
wouldn't be fighting this alone so like
it's okay not to be okay it's not okay
not to ask for someone in back yeah
to the families who live with the loss
or losses of loved ones they didn't do
that to hurt you
or destroy your life they they took
their lives because they were struggling
in a great deal of emotional mental pain
suicide mental illness and addiction are
the only diseases that we blame the
person for perpetually but people die
from suicide just like they die from any
other organ diseased today no matter the
pain I'm in no matter the struggles I
experience I do believe that life is the
greatest gift we've ever been given and
if you're suffering mentally don't wait
like I did sitting in denial for so long
because recovery happens living proof
you